midhealth plan the sponsors of this next
segment have partnered with the ymca for
a back-to-school community health fair
and pool party tomorrow in true vegas
fashion iman mcfarland of silver summit
and brianna barber of durango hills ymca
are here to invite you and your family
welcome ladies thank you for having us
thank you i'm excited to talk about this
it's not quite vegas strip pool party
though no this is a family event okay so
tell us about the partnership between
both organizations first and foremost
who wants to go first go ahead all right
i'll do it um so the ymca
is looking for different ways to support
community health and what better way to
do that than with our managed care
organizations and our medical providers
such as silver summit health plan so
that's kind of how the discussion
started
is to help our our community get
healthier in a multitude of different
ways absolutely now what about summer
summit silver summit health plan you
know is different about the others in
the area absolutely well silver summit
is a managed care plan delivering high
quality health insurance to the people
of nevada
through medicaid medicare in the nevada
health insurance marketplace
their goal is to improve the quality of
life for every nevadan one person at a
time and so partnering with great
community organizations like the ymca is
the way to empower our members to take
an active participant participation in
building a high quality life absolutely
and you know what better way to do that
than have some fun right so let's talk
about what's happening tomorrow at the
pool party and the fair
well to kick it off
while supplies last everyone that comes
through the door will get a free
backpack stuffed with school supplies
great on top of that they'll be having
access to the ymca's water park we will
have dental and vision screenings as
well as free haircuts massage therapy
that's incredible
caricature artists and so much more and
this is a free event why is that such a
blessing for families out there well
it's important for them to have
opportunities to do things that are
affordable for their family and as we
know everything is getting more and more
expensive so this is an opportunity for
you to bring your family out bring your
kids out have some fun have some access
to resources as well
immunizations as well you guys are
giving those out too that's really
important organizations health
screenings wellness screenings
we will be having food trucks as well so
kids can come get milkshakes and burgers
for free that is great and entertainment
you guys have it all set up for all the
families tomorrow 4 to 8 p.m correct all
right be there everybody thank you to
silver summit health plan for sponsoring
this segment their back-to-school
community health fair and pool party
with the ymca is tomorrow from 4-8 again
located at the durango hills ymca free
to attend once again i want you all to
know that and we will be right back